bonsoir à tous nouvelle édition à
l'heure américaine nous sommes ce soir à
washington la capitale fédérale juste
devant la maison blanche c'est là que
les terroristes auraient voulu frapper
tout à l'heure un expert de
l'antiterrorisme nous en dira plus c'est
là que la riposte se décidera si elle a
lieu et puis c'est là aussi que jacques
chirac est attendue dans les prochaines
heures d'abord les titres de l'actualité
de ce mardi israël annonce un retrait de
tous les territoires autonomes occupés
en palestine il s'agit de mettre à
l'épreuve les propositions de cessez le
feu formulées par l'autorité
palestinienne la fin de non-recevoir des
talibans au à l'ultimatum pakistanais de
ne livrerons pas ben laden sous sans
preuves de son implication dans les
attentats du temps à kaboul et puis
l'actualité française laurent fabius a
présenté un budget inchangé malgré les
menaces de récession agravée par les
attentats aux états unis il est avec
nous laurent fabius en duplex bonsoir et
à tout à l'heure nous vous entendront
aussi sur les réseaux financiers les
facilités financières dont a bénéficié
oussama ben laden
merci de votre attention priorité à
l'actualité nous allons donc tout de
suite en israël avec cette annonce d'un
retrait de tous les territoires
autonomes occupé première mise en
application puisque les chars israéliens
se sont retirés de djénine alors on
pense bien sûr au choc provoquée par les
attentats américain et puis aussi aux
pressions américaines qui ont suivi sur
israël charles enderlin
oui tout à fait pour comprendre ce qu'il
vient d'arriver il faut revenir à
vendredi dernier ariel sharon avait
répondu par une fin de non recevoir au
président bush qui lui demandait
d'autoriser une rencontre entre yasser
arafat et shimon peres pour discuter
d'un cessez-le-feu depuis le premier
ministre israélien a fait marche arrière
il ne peut pas se permettre d'être le
seul chef de gouvernement occidental à
répondre par la négative à une demande
du président des états unis dans cette
crise hier il a envoyé son fils omri
omri sharon rencontré secrètement yasser
arafat à gaza la discussion a été
fructueuse à cesser le feu est
apparemment en train de se mettre en
place il ya des mesures concrètes qui se
passe sur le terrain il faut encore être
prudent il ya des combats à hébron
également dans le sud de la bande de
gaza mais pour la première fois depuis
le 28 septembre 2000 il ya une réelle
chance d'assez c'est le feu au proche
orient
peut être une nouvelle donne donc donc
pression sur les israéliens pression
aussi sur yasser arafat avec cette
promesse d'un cessez-le-feu charles tout
à fait les américains ont lancé à yasser
arafat un véritable ultimatum il a un
délai très court quelques semaines pour
ramener le calme dans les territoires
palestiniens et aussi agir contre le
ramasse et contre le jihad islamique
des organisations que l'administration
bush considèrent comme terroriste et la
yasser arafat est un réel problème il
risque de se passer des choses
importantes sur le terrain parce que les
islamistes ne l'entendront pas de cette
oreille
merci charles vérification bien sûr dans
les prochains jours de ses engagements
de part et d'autre un retour donc ici à
washington l'émotion bien sûr et moins
intense qu'à new york le bilan fait état
d'à peu près 180 morts pour l'instant
mais bien entendu on a ressenti comme un
choc très fort de voir des cibles
militaires ou civiles prises d'assaut
par les terroristes regardez ces images
d'abord ces images du pentagone tourné
quelques heures quelques minutes même
après le bombardement par les pompiers
elle sont commentés par etienne
leenhardt et puis on se retrouvera à
côté de ce qu'on appelle ici le bunker
mardi 11 septembre dernier il est un peu
plus de neuf heures du matin l'épaisse
colonne de fumée noire qui s'échappe du
pentagone vient illustrer l'inimaginable
c'est énorme forteresse le bâtiment que
l'un se pose et être le mieux défendu de
tous les états unis vient d'être
éventrée par un avion de lit
cinq jours plus tard avec les sauveteurs
au rez-de-chaussée de l'ale qui a été
touché
l'explosion du boeing d'american
airlines bourré de carburant puisqu'il
venait de décoller d'un aéroport tout
proche à tout soufflé sur son passage
à l'heure qu'il est sur les 180
personnes officiellement portées
disparues
ici à washington
onze seulement ont pu être identifiés
si la structure résiste l'on
reconstruira au plus vite la partie
endommagée
les vingt mille militaires qui chaque
jour farraj qu'ici dans le centre
nerveux du système de défense le plus
sophistiqué du monde garderont toutefois
longtemps et comme toute l'amérique
le sentiment désormais d'être vulnérable
en 58 ans le pentagone et ses 28
kilomètres de couloirs n'avait jamais
été attaqué lorsque ça s'est produit le
secrétaire à la défense donald rumsfeld
était dans son bureau mais il est situé
à l'opposé de l'endroit où s'est produit
l'attaqué alors là aussi comme ailleurs
sur les sites attaqués aux états unis il
ya toujours des gens qui viennent se
recueillir au moment où regarder tout
simplement le dieu par exemple
pouvez vous me dire ce que vous êtes en
nutrition
american airlines est en ce moment en
effet la lutte à la sauce ans
alors évidemment ses sentiments sur mon
touch et dont j entend discuter parisien
penser de tout ça
c'est une tragédie tragédie qui s'est
écrite arisée c'est une des choses les
plus horribles genou a ajouté que tous
leurs soucis patrice dans l'espace d'une
journée
voilà il y adeux l'inquiétude ici on se
sent bien et il y a des signes qui ne
trompent pas exemple l'aéroport de
washington le plus proche du
centre-ville donc tout près des centres
de pouvoir n'a pas ouvert ses portes on
se demande même si ils leur ouvrira un
jour pascal golomer pascal caron en
temps normal les aérogares accueille 45
mille passagers chaque jour aérogare
fantôme depuis une semaine déserte et
silencieuse alors que partout ailleurs
aux états unis le trafic a repris
normalement l'aéroport national de
washington lui reste fermé aucun des
avions détournés par les terroristes là
pourtant décoller d'ici mais les pistes
ne se trouve qu'à quelques centaines de
mètres du pentagone de la maison blanche
et du capitole cette proximité jusqu
alors un atout est devenu aujourd'hui un
handicap
nous faisons partie de l'ensemble des
bâtiments fédéraux et nous comprenons
que le gouvernement vérifiera chaque
immeuble fédéral le pentagone la façon
dont on va le reconstruire
et bien sûr ils se demandent ce que l'on
va faire ici dans cet aéroport du fait
de notre emplacement
les avions n'ont jamais été autorisés à
survoler la ville mais faudra-t-il des
mesures de sécurité supplémentaires
voire une fermeture définitive rien
n'était encore décidé pour us airways
qui a fait de cet aéroport plus de ses
places fortes
la situation est déjà critique la
direction a annoncé hier onze mille
suppressions d'emplois
soit réduire le nombre de vols de 25%
alors garder le même nombre de salariés
ils ne peuvent pas se le permettre
mais les concurrents de us airways sont
tout aussi inquiets car les américains
annuler par milliers leurs réservations
de vols à la bourse le cours des actions
a plongé de moitié les différentes
compagnies ont réclamé un plan d aide
d'urgence à la maison blanche 25
milliards de dollars c'est ce dont elles
ont besoin maintenant pour éviter une
catastrophe économique et sociale dans
quelques semaines
on retrouve dans la banlieue de
washington pour une question qui n'a pas
encore reçu vraiment de réponse l'un des
avions visé t-il la maison blanche alors
cette question à la pause et à l'un des
spécialistes de l'antiterrorisme
et pour cause puisqu'il a été lui-même
responsable de l'antiterrorisme à la cia
pendant plusieurs années
be nice cannes istres à notre merci de
nous accueillir chez vous bonjour la
maison blanche etait-elle la cible de
l'un des avions est ce qu on a une
réponse là dessus aujourd'hui
il semble en effet que l'un des avions
s'apprêtait à s'écraser sur la maison
blanche et il semble aussi que les
autorités ont reçu des informations
précises alors que les appareils était
encore en vol et notamment celui qui
s'est écrasé ensuite en pennsylvanie
après une bagarre dans le cockpit
on entend on entend beaucoup dire que
les services secrets américains ont voté
parce qu'on a délaissé le renseignement
humain au profit du renseignement
électronique on dit par exemple quand on
n'a plus le droit aujourd'hui à la cia
de prendre des informateurs qui sont
recherchés pour trim est ce que c'est un
vrai problème selon vous
vous savez la cia ces dernières années a
été très critiquée notamment par le
pouvoir politique et le congrès est
utilisée qu'à la cia et bien certains
agents notamment en amérique latine
comme étaient de véritables exactions
sur des personnes donc on a fait partir
tous ces gens de la cia c'est un gros
problème
vous pouvez pas infiltré ces groupes
terroristes sans avoir des espions qui
n'hésite pas à se salir les mains
c'est malheureux mais ce boulot là n'est
pas pour des enfants de choeur
mais bon ces gens essaient de nous tuer
et vous devez à tout prix obtenir des
informations est le seul moyen de le
faire est de les infiltrer et la cia
n'en fera pas l'économie il faut envoyer
des commandos en afghanistan pour
capturer ben laden
oui les etats unis doivent envoyer des
commandos des forces spéciales
je ne vois pas une occupation militaire
massive en afghanistan c'est impossible
techniquement et puis les états unis ne
vont pas d'intérêt stratégique et majeur
dans ce pays
je pense qu'ils doivent envoyer des
commandos et essayer de capturer ben
laden
il y aura des morts c'est évident mais
c'est une déclaration de guerre
cinq mille personnes ont été tuées dans
cet attentat terroriste c'est du jamais
vu dans notre histoire
et nous devons répondre nous ne pouvons
pas rester passifs mais on doit répondre
de façon appropriée et si les services
secrets sont sur la sellette on s'est
aussi interrogé sur les capacités de
george bush à faire face à une crise
d'une telle ampleur les sondages du sens
favorable mais la presse s'interroge
newsweek par exemple on y lit george's
bush n'a jamais voulu être un héros
seulement un président mais aujourd'hui
le pays attend qu'il mette la barre
fluos alors ce qui compte par dessus
tout dans ces cas là c'est le verbe la
parole l'éloquence et parfois même la
grandiloquence et aussi une
particularité américaine analyse de la
parole de george bush jean marc qu'ils
george bush a choisi d'appliquer le mot
guerre à des actes de terrorisme au sens
de dictionnaire le mot guerre s'applique
à la lutte armée entre états comme la
guerre du golfe
des conventions internationales
définissent la guerre comme des crimes
contre la paix les personnes mais
aujourd'hui israéliens et palestiniens
chacun à leur manière utilise le mot
guerre pour évoquer indifféremment
terrorisme occupation ou représailles
aux
croisades à deux sens celui historique
d'expédition chrétienne pour délivrer
les lieux saints occupée par les
musulmans et par extension le sens de
campagne exemple croisades contre la
faim
le mot fait écho à celui de djihad
littéralement effort spirituel ou
physique et au sens religieux ou
politiques guerre sainte pour propager
ou défendre l'islam
- just
cet avis de recherche mondial du fbi
aida pourtant de 1993 et des premiers
attentats anti-américains imputé à
ossama ben laden dans la bouche du texan
d'orge gauche
l'allusion la conquête de l'ouest est
bien comprise par l'amérique profonde
mais alors a cependant choqué à
l'étranger ce qui musulmans ou non
accuse l'oncle sam de vouloir être le
shérif de la planète
nous avons un problème de liaison en
direct avec washington david pujadas
nous allons tenter de rétablir la
liaison pour l'heure voyons la suite du
déroulé de ce journal et l'émotion à la
maison blanche aujourd'hui george bush
et plusieurs centaines de ses
collaborateurs ont observé une minute de
silence en hommage aux victimes des
attentats
voilà pour cette image de la maison
blanche alors à new york depuis six
jours sept jours même exactement plus
aucun survivant n'a été retrouvé dans
les décombres du world trade center le
nombre de disparus a encore augmenté il
s'élève aujourd'hui à
5873 les familles des victimes se presse
auprès des cellules de crise pour
identifier leurs proches c'est un
reportage poignant signé yasmina farber
et edwards père
la police des ménages les barrières de
sécurité bar d'eads affiche de disparus
l entouraient la première cellule de
crise c'est désormais dans un hangar sur
le quai 94 que les proches des victimes
viennent consulter les listes des
personnes blessées ou mortes à chacun
son histoire
christine a fait le voyage de floride
pour chercher jimmy sa fille de 23 ans
alors que le maire de new york demande
aux familles de se préparer à
l'inéluctable
m
si les secouristes de la ville qui les
états unis veulent laisser tomber qu'ils
laissent les familles des disparus aller
sur place et risquer leur ration tous
ceux à qui j'en ai parlé très près à le
faire
mais vous savez le gouvernement veut
tout contrôler l acier prisonnière là
bas était mon enfant c'est moi qui l'ait
mise au monde pas à eux ils n'ont pas le
droit de me l'apprendre
les familles des meetings les disparus
sont priés d'apporter les effets
personnels de leurs proches pour
déterminer l'adn l'empreinte génétique
et apporter une brosse à dents et aussi
son rasoir
pouvait encore sentir l'odeur de sa
lotion après rasage
une semaine après le drame le soutien
psychologique est plus que jamais
indispensable
nerveusement la situation est
insupportable
les familles ont un chemin difficile à
faire parce que c'est une histoire sans
fin les gens noirs rien pour faire leur
pub
je sais pas jusqu'a ce que l'on ferait
rentrer à la maison je suppose
dans le dos de michael un message
garanties solides comme pour dire qu'il
faut espérer une rapide les familles des
disparus ne veulent pas se résigner à
imaginer le pire pour elle toute la
puissance américaine peut être mises en
oeuvre pour retrouver des survivants
c'est une priorité avant de songer à
faire la guerre
voilà nous sommes de retour aux
etats-unis
5856 morts ou disparus c'est donc le
nouveau bilan qui avait été donné par le
maire de new york tout à l'heure pas
très loin de là quelques centaines de
mètres le quartier des affaires aux
traités les rues environnantes ont
repris vie hier puisque la bourse a
redémarré à cette occasion de nombreux
employés ont re découvert leurs bureaux
dans des conditions
bien sûr difficile de la poussière des
débris
ccc retrouvailles avec ses bureaux que
nous raconte maintenant stéphane
breitner et olivier robert
les affaires reprennent enfin fresque
trade celle vannes rouvre sa boutique
d'électronique fermé depuis une semaine
perte sèche cinq cent mille francs les
premiers clients arrivent au compte
goutte et il ne s'attend pas en voir
beaucoup dans les prochaines semaines
les deux tours nous amener beaucoup de
touristes dont le quartier îles et
touristes c'est notre fonds de commerce
avec cette catastrophe ils seront
beaucoup moins nombreux
c'est l'un des rares à avoir levé son
rideau dans cette rue qui mène à wall
street les stigmates du double attentat
sont encore bien présents
parfois le nettoyage a commencé des
tonnes de poussière a enlevé pour
redonner un peu de vie au quartier
faut bien commencer un jour votre sabre
il faut que ça soit beau
faut pas s'arrêter là vie doit continuer
il y en a d'autres qui ont aussi
beaucoup de travail en perspective les
employés des sociétés de nettoyage
sortent leur artillerie pour s'attaquer
aux bureaux devant la police et l'armée
qui veillent toujours au point de
contrôle ceux qui vont travailler à côté
des ruines du world trade center emmène
un peu plus que leurs sacoches en tenue
décontractée eux aussi vont jouer les
nettoyeurs
à cause de la fumée le bureau est très
sale alors je vais aller nettoyer
repartir du bon pied c'est aussi ce que
voudrait pedro fernandes depuis ce matin
ce corps d'annie retrouve les clients
habituels de wall street ses gestes sont
toujours aussi énergique mais le moral à
dumas la suite
me sens mal très mal je suis inquiet
pour l'avenir mais il faut bien
commencer à travailler
le quartier du world trade center est
encore loin d'avoir retrouvé une
activité normale à la fin de l'année
s'annonce donc difficile surtout que la
plupart des commerçants de possèdent pas
d'assurance
voilà on revient maintenant sur george
bush face à la crise avec vous et yen
alors on a vu que dans ses discours dans
ses paroles l'évocation de dieu était
très très régulier on a l'impression que
religion et politique sont très
imbriquées oui absolument serré que god
bless america est devenu un petit peu le
lean le nouvel hymne national on a
entendu god bless america mis un petit
peu à toutes les sauces donc que dieu
bénisse l'amérique mais c'est dû à
plusieurs choses d'abord aux
circonstances de cette tragédie qui est
sans précédent aux états unis ensuite
peut-être au fait que 90% des américains
affirment pratiquer une religion donc un
pays extrêmement croyants et puis à la
personnalité de georges bush lui-même
qui vous savez et très croyants avaient
fait dans sa campagne de la religion là
aussi un de ses seins de ses mots
d'ordre est ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre c'est qu'ici aux états unis
il annonce il ya une séparation
naturelle entre l'église et l'état il
n'y a pas de séparation entre la
religion et la politique
on parlait des sondages c'est vrai qu'on
a le sentiment qu'il ya une union sacrée
autour de georges on s'interroge
beaucoup sur ses capacités en europe ici
apparemment ce n'est quand même pas
vraiment le cas en tout cas dans
l'opinion oui il ya un décalage très
claire entre la façon dont on europe on
a jugé les les capacités de george bush
a géré cette crise dans les premiers
jours et le soutien massif que lui ont
apportés les américains c'est vrai qu'il
ya eu des cafouillages au départ on en a
beaucoup parlé c'est vrai que george
bush en termes de de rhétorique anti
mais aussi en terme de comportement
c'est beaucoup rattraper il était très
ému il s'est comporté un petit peu en en
chef de guerre et on a l'impression en
tout cas pour l'instant et bien qu'il
ait qu'il allait les habits qu'il a la
carrure pour mener ce conflit va bien à
la george bush qui recevra dans quelques
heures maintenant à dîner jacques chirac
le premier chef d'état étranger à venir
lui rendre visite depuis les attentats
il ya un autre signe de cette
mobilisation de tous les américains à
propos de ces attentats c'est l'enquète
le fbi a demandé aux gens de collaborer
et il a reçu plus de 32000 message le
chiffre a été rendu public hier sur
internet des messages téléphoniques des
témoignages sur d'éventuelles pistes que
pour être explorées est les policiers
alors à propos de cette enquête le fbi a
essaye surtout de remonter la trace des
kamikazes qui ont tous été identifiés
regardez par exemple ce reportage sur
l'homme dont on pense qu'ils
conduisaient l'avion qui s'est écrasé en
pennsylvanie
on a remonté sa trace jusque en
allemagne et bien entendu ses proches
tombe des nues gilles marine est
tout sourire ils dansent c'était il ya
18 mois au liban cciab samir jarre a
célébré le mariage d'un cousin ce jeune
homme de 26 ans est il déjà un soldat de
la guerre sainte sait-il qu'il
accomplira une mission suicide en tous
les cas il n'en laisse rien paraître
même auprès de sa famille
il est innocent je ne les jamais élevé
dans la haine
je n'ai jamais fait de mal à une mouche
nous ne sommes pas des extrémistes
saïd samir jara avait quitté le liban il
ya cinq ans pour l'allemagne hambourg il
étudiait l'aéronautique et cela qu'il
aurait rencontré mohammed atta l'un des
pilotes suicide et cela qu'il aurait pu
être recruté ses amis eux non plus n'ont
rien vu
il était toujours bonne humeur il
plaisantait l'autoroute et pouvait se
moquer de lui
kanji veut pas croire qu'il ait pu faire
une chose sauf que
depuis quelques semaines il prenait des
cours de pilotage en floride le 11
septembre il emprunte comme simple
passager l'un des avions suicides le vol
93 qui va s'écraser un pennsylvanie pour
le fbi asiad samir jara était
vraisemblablement le pilote kamikaze
voilà et le fbi pense donc tous ces
hommes étaient reliés par un élément
commun l'appartenance à l'organisation
secrète d'oussama ben laden vous savez
qui hier le pakistan aurait lancé un
ultimatum à l'afghanistan livrez-nous
ben laden ou bien nous arrêterons de
vous soutenir et bien la réponse est
venue aujourd'hui l'afghanistan donc
indique pas question de livrer oussama
ben laden sans preuve formelle de son
implication dans ces attentats regardez
cette photo c'est un document rare il
s'agit du chef spirituel des talibans du
guide des talibans le mollah omar
ces photos sont extrêmement rares ce
document date de 1986 il avait alors 31
ans entre temps le chef de talibans
était blessé à un oeil il est devenu
borgne le mollah omar c'est bien sûr un
ami approche aujourd'hui d'oussama ben
laden donc voilà pour cette réponse des
afghans au pakistan ou deux
nombreux hommes du fbi ont débarqué il
ya quelques jours les premiers signes de
mécontentement sont perceptibles
manifestation aujourd'hui dans les rues
d'islamabad c'est un reportage de
bertrand cocq et de philippe jasmin
d'encens d'une manifestation
anti-américaine
hier on brûler le drapeau américain
aujourd'hui c'était des étudiants
islamistes 5000 qui défilait à karachi
aux cris de nous sommes tous des
talibans
islamabad est plus tranquille en fin
d'après-midi le son de cliquer pour les
élèves d'une école coranique dont les
pères tiennent boutique au marché
d'apparat tout un petit peuple musulman
qui sans interrompre ses activités suit
de près la montée des périls
ce libraire islamistes nous dit que de
tous les ouvrages de ben laden il n'en a
plus un seul tous épuisés souvent leur
foi se confond avec leurs convictions
grâce à dieu jamais les américains
deviendront chez nous
les pakistanais n'accepte parc des non
musulmans viennent chez eux tuer des
musulmans nous ne le permettrons pas
le gouvernement pakistanais est
l'esclave des américains
et si on arrête ben laden alors il y
aura encore plus de terrorisme
et peu importe que leurs gouvernements
fassent allégeance à l'amérique plus de
la rue les obligations diplomatiques ne
sont rien au regard de la solidarité
musulmane
alors que l'heure de la confrontation
approche la population pakistanaise a
déjà choisi son camp et ce n'est
clairement pas celui de la mairie
voilà on s'interroge souvent sur les
relations entre le pakistan et
l'afghanistan relation complexifier par
le fait que certaines régions du
pakistan sont largement peuplée
d'afghans à des réfugiés mais aussi des
personnes qui finalement a s'insère dans
le tissu économique local peshawar par
exemple tout près de la frontière c'est
un reportage d'agnès vahramian et de
gilles jacquier
le fusil à pompe et la sécurité du
coffre fort a dit mohammad est un riche
commerçant de peshawar les téléphones
sommes depuis dubaï karachi islamabad
l'homme et sa famille ont fait fortune
au pakistan dans le commerce de ces 4 4
beaucoup de commerces ici et les
pakistanais sont très jaloux il ya la
paix d'abord construire notre pays la
pianiste en
peshawar et son bazar argent pour les
femmes ici même sont les talibans la
tradition est la plus forte on croise
toutes les générations de réfugiés
depuis 30 ans ceux qui ont fui la guerre
avec les russes puis les conflits entre
les factions afghanes et enfin la misère
et la sécheresse
dans cette échoppe cet homme raconte
qu'il ne gagne que quelques dizaines de
francs par mois
ne pas retourner chez nous on n'est pas
des serpents pour manger juste des vers
de terre il n'y a rien là bas
le long des eaux souillées de la rivière
kaboul une école offre pour 30 euros par
mois une somme ici l'apprentissage de
quelques aides anglais
ces enfants n'ont pour la plupart pas
connu l'origine talibans ni même été en
afghanistan
il ne pourrait pas là bas qui requiert
des connaissances
ils ne peuvent faire que ce n'est pas
possible du tout même d'être éduqué
vraiment en afghanistan du titien diane
roy n'a pas à la périphérie de peshawar
les premiers camps de réfugiés offre
l'image de bidonvilles en torchis le
pakistan expulse tous les jours des
afghans mais le pays ne sais pas comment
cette population réagira en quatre ans
oui l'exode en afghanistan continue par
crainte des représailles américaines les
rares témoins décrivent kaboul comme une
ville morte menacées par la famine et
les épidémies écouter le journaliste de
rtl mathieu jégo il a pu se rendre à
kaboul son témoignage recueilli lors de
son retour à la frontière
d'après ce que j'ai pu voir les le
marché par exemple étaient quasiment
vides hier après midi d'un magasin avait
dû fermer leur vie ce matin donc j'ai
pris la route avec beaucoup de cas bulli
qui désiraient fuir s'il désirait partir
du pays le plus vite possible car la
rumeur voulait que les américains
attaquent l'afghanistan aujourd'hui donc
l'inquiétude vraiment grosse lit et les
gens prennent doute leurs économies pour
se payer le ticket de bulles qui leur
permettra d'atteindre la frontière
salvatrice de problème c'est que les
tarifs ont été multipliées par trois en
deux jours il fallait débourser 300
roupies famille dernier il faut
maintenant débourser environ 1000 rouge
c'est-à-dire sans france en france est
l'équivalent d'un salaire mensuel là-bas
à kaboul vous vous imaginez que beaucoup
de gens finalement ne se pose même pas
partir ils sont
prisonniers dans leur ville puisqu'ils
n'ont pas les moyens d'acheter un ticket
de bus ou de louer une voiture pour se
rendre à la frontière pakistanaise
une question revient à toujours comment
l'un des hommes les plus recherchés du
monde et depuis plusieurs années peut
continuer à gérer sa fortune à gérer ses
biens ce sont les réseaux financier
d'oussama ben laden enquête olivier
carottes et vanessa rôle
dans ces vidéos de propagande
il y a une arme qu'oussama ben laden ne
manipule jamais devant les caméras
c'est pourtant larmes la plus importante
pour lui l'argent lui couper les vivres
c'est désormais une priorité pour les
enquêteurs première piste l'argent qui
pourrait être caché par le clan ben
laden
paris quartier des champs-elysées une
partie de la famille ben laden vit ici
dans cet immeuble
sur l'interphone le nom a été effacé
mais on répond encore aux visites à
bonjour une nous sommes de france 2 nous
voulons rencontrer monsieur ben laden
officiellement toute sa famille
cinquante quatre frères et soeurs a
rompu totalement avec oussama ben laden
depuis sept ans cette famille richissime
est basé en arabie saoudite
elle a des intérêts financiers dans le
monde entier en france elle possède par
exemple cette petite entreprise une
fabrique de tuyaux une maison d'édition
plutôt fantomatique y est également
domicilié plus troublant plus sensibles
l'une des nombreuses banques de la
famille à lugano en suisse fraîchement
débaptiser elle s'appelait al taqwa
oussama ben laden at il gardé des liens
avec ces structures c'est la thèse de ce
livre
c'est des liens qui depuis 94 ne sont
plus des liens directs puisque en 94
oussama ben laden a été déchu de sa
nationalité saoudienne mais pour un
prince pour un fils de famille saoudiens
ce qui est important c'est pas la
nationalité c'est le lien de faron tel
c'est le lien de son et on le sait
d'après plusieurs sources autorisées
comme on dit que ses liens avec la
famille n'ont pas été rompus seconde
piste les paradis fiscaux cet après midi
cet homme l'ancien directeur de la cia
en a désigné un chypre pour oussama ben
laden cette île de méditerranée
aurait été une plaque tournante il s'en
serait servi pour placer discrètement
plusieurs centaines de millions de
dollars venus notamment du soudan de
l'argent que lui avait confié en 1993
hassan al tourabi le chef de
l'opposition islamiste
cet argent il ya une parquet qui va
placer à court terme notre moyen terme
une autre à long terme il ya une partie
de cet argent qu'il va
transformer en liquidités parce qu'il
sait que les commandos terroristes ont
besoin d'argent liquide pour assurer
leur protection et ne pas être repérés
avant leurs actes oussama ben laden
capitaliste avisé qui va même se servir
pour faire circuler son argent
d'associations humanitaires c la
troisième piste les ong tout le monde
peut donner
défaut à ces ong y compris les cons
trier les contribuables américains qui
sont défiscalisées et puis c'est une
couverture caritative social qui permet
d'avoir un instrument supplémentaire de
financement cachés dans les montagnes
d'afghanistan oussama ben laden peut-il
encore contrôler tous ces capitaux pour
les experts il n'a même plus besoin une
armée de financiers le ferait à sa place
voilà l'a dit laurent fabius on profite
de votre présence pour vous poser la
question est ce que la réponse au
terrorisme n'est pas certes militaires
et policières les aussi financière en
limitant les possibilités de manoeuvre
dans les paradis fiscaux par exemple ou
autre certainement parce que un attentat
comme celui du 11-septembre demande par
sa préparation par son déroulement des
moyens financiers considérables
donc c'est vrai qu'il y à travers les
paradis fiscaux à travers d'autres
techniques
l'instrument financier du terrorisme par
rapport à ça qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire
qu'est ce qu'on doit faire
d'une part il existe une organisme
international qui s'appelle le gafi le
groupe d'action financière
internationale qui a déjà fait un
travail qui est utile pour les paradis
fiscaux mais que nous devons sens très
bien davantage sur
la lutte contre le financement du
terrorisme et très prochainement lorsque
nous nous réunirons avec mes collègues
du g7 des ministres des finances je
demanderai dans la france que l'action
du gafi soit centré sur cet aspect
deuxièmement vous savez peut-être qu'il
y à une convention qui est intervenu à
l'onu sur ces problèmes du terrorisme et
du financement à l'instigation de la
france n'est pas encore ratifié par tous
je pense que l'europe dans ce domaine
devraient absolument exemplaire et
montrer qu'on peut avancer puis
troisièmement dans ce ministère lui-même
je viens de prendre la décision de créer
une cellule particulière
spécialisée dans la lutte contre le
financement du terrorisme qui groupe
rang particulier les impôts les douanes
le trésor et vous savez probablement par
ailleurs que la commission des
opérations de bourse en liaison avec ses
homologues étrangères est en train de
mener une enquête sur des mouvements
financiers qui auraient pu intervenir
mais il faut resserrer dispositif alors
justement ac est absolument ce
financement oui justement laurent fabius
est question c'est vrai ajoute à
l'horreur de ces attentats question ceux
qui les ont téléguidé ont-ils spéculer
en bourse on sait que les actions des
compagnies aériennes et des compagnies
d'assurance ont chuté deux jours avant
les attentats autrement dit ceux qui les
ont organisés ont-ils vendus très
opportunément leurs actions la cob a
ouvert une enquête reportage séverine
lebrun jean-françois chevet
des ordres d'achat et de vente d'actions
les salles de marché comme celle ci on
manipule des milliers par jour des
ordres passés sur certains titres juste
avant les attentats du 11 septembre aux
états unis intrigue au plus haut point
la cob le gendarme de la bourse il y à
des types qui semble avoir baissé dans
les conditions
un peu bizarre
à ce moment là la seule la seule
solution pour nous c'est d'essayer de
regarder quelles étaient les grands
donneurs d'ordres de vente et d'achat et
vous pour voir quelles étaient leurs
motivations
sur l' enquête il ne dira rien de plus
les soupçons portent notamment sur
l'étrange baisse des cours de l'action
de certaines compagnies d'assurance par
exemple l'assureur allemand munich re et
perd subitement 13 % de sa valeur la
semaine avant l'attentât même phénomène
chez axa -10 % on relève notamment une
vente d'actions étonnante entre le 4 et
le 7 septembre
certains savent est il que les twin
towers assuré en partie par axa allait
s'effondrer entraînant la chute
spectaculaire de l'action du groupe
français - 13% après l'impact des avions
kamikazes s'il enquête devait démontrer
la réalité de ces spéculations macabre
ce serait alors le premier exemple de
délit d'initié terroristes
autre question avant d'en venir au
budget la chute des bourses et respect
finalement assez limité on a eu
l'impression qu'il ya une prise de
conscience les banques centrales ont
beaucoup faire des eu l'impression que y
avait une coopération entre les grands
organismes financiers nationaux ou
internationaux laurent fabius et c'est
vrai qu'on a une sentiment d'éviter le
pire à l'en avant d'en venir au budget
juste cette question est-ce que vous
avez l'impression qu'il ya peut-être une
nouvelle donne ou qu'il ya vraiment eu
une action concertée contre le cours des
choses pour éviter un crash et une
récession c'est tout à fait exact
il y a eu à la fois l'action concertée
des banques centrales et en particulier
de la federal reserve la banque
américaine et de la banque centrale
européenne qui ont très bien agi
notamment la banque centrale européenne
puisqu'elle a baissé de 0,5 point ses
taux d'intérêt ce qui est un élément
pour faire repartir la machine
économique ça a été filmé à concerter et
nous mêmes les ministres des finances
au niveau européen comme entre l'europe
et l'amérique et à d'autres niveaux nous
sommes intervenus de façon concertée
pour faire en sorte qu'il n'y ait pas de
ça va continuer oui ça va continuer bien
sûr ça va continuer aussi bien du g7
vendredi nous avons une réunion des
ministres des finances européens et
d'une façon générale face à un phénomène
comme le terrorisme et compte tenu des
risques qui peuvent exister sur le plan
financier nous devons agir de façon
concertée il n'ya pas seulement
d'ailleurs le risque financier qui était
endiguée il ya le risque pétrolier
peut-être on en parlera dans un instant
et puis il ya le risque économique sur
la psychologie sur la consommation sur
les ménages
voilà alors c'est dans ce contexte que
vous avez présenté votre budget 2012
laurent fabius un budget finalement qui
ne tient pas compte de ces événements
qui pourraient affecter l'économie
mondiale vous allez nous expliquer dans
un instant d'abord le détail des
chiffres avec penny leroy nous rendons
public présenté son premier budget en
euros et dans un contexte mondial
perturbé l'exercice est difficile mais
laurent fabius aux quand même le pari
l'économie française devrait bien
résister aux effets des attentats aux
états unis dans l'hypothèse de base du
budget 2002 une croissance l'an prochain
de deux et demi pour cent soit un peu
plus qu'en 2001 parmi les dépenses
prioritaires l'éducation pour la
première fois son budget dépasse 400
milliards de francs laurent fabius
compte également renforcé la sécurité
avec la création de 3000 postes d'agents
de police et deux mille gendarmes même
chose dans la justice avec 3000 nouveaux
emplois au total l'état embauchera 15
1900 fonctionnaires en 2002 autre
mystère favoriser l'environnement et la
culture qui dépasse la barre symbolique
de 1 % du budget 39 milliards de francs
en tout seront consacrés aux allègements
d'impôts la prime pour l'emploi sera
doublé l'impôt sur le revenu continuera
à baisser la taxe professionnelle et
l'impôt sur les sociétés devrait
également diminuer
alors certain laurent fabius vous trouve
très optimiste on écoute françois
d'aubert pour démocratie libérale et
patrick devedjian pour le rpr il tient
absolument pas compte
de la situation internationale qui a
dramatiquement changé depuis mardi
dernier il ne tient pas compte du
ralentissement qui avait déjà avant
l'accrochage tueur américaine il ne
tient pas compte des graves
déséquilibres de nos finances publiques
c'est à dire qu on a trop de dépenses et
les recettes ont du mal à rentrer et il
tient compte du seul chose des élections
c'est surtout un budget de gens qui sont
coincés par la politique qu'ils ont
conduit précédemment c'est à dire qu'ils
n'ont plus de marge de manoeuvre
le déficit budgétaire est déjà très
important et parce qu'ils ne l'ont pas
diminué dans la période de croissance
les recettes fiscales sont en diminution
parce que ils n'ont pas fait les
investissements qu'il fallait au moment
de la période de croissance et que nos
entreprises ne sont plus adaptés à la
compétition internationale est donc
évidemment c'est un budget qui ne répond
pas aux défis d'aujourd'hui
alors laurent fabius c'est ce qu'il ne
fallait pas repenser les grands
équilibres de ce budget à la lumière des
récents attentats et des conséquences
qu'ils peuvent avoir sur l'économie
d'abord un mot par rapport à ces
réactions d'un soft nombre de personnes
de l'opposition
bon qu'est le langage habituels de
l'opposition mais je pense que ça ne va
pas bien au delà tout de même une
remarque pour vous qui êtes aux états
unis depuis quand même frappé de voir
que par rapport à des événements de
cette gravité qui touche les américains
mais qui nous touche aussi là bas on se
soude on ne se pose pas de questions on
se dit on va surmonter les difficultés
et en france et toute une série de gens
qui au lieu de se dire comment va-t-on
surmonter les difficultés qui est déjà
partie perdante par deux battus moi je
ne suis pas de ceux là je pense que la
france a la capacité de surmonter les
difficultés alors par rapport à ce
budget comme vous l'avez très bien
analyser il ya deux axes principaux
d'abord on met l'accent sur quelques
priorités très peu nombreuses
essentiellement l'emploi et l'éducation
et la sécurité parce que ce sont les
points centraux et on se donne les
moyens pour avancer et puis nous
continuons les allègements d'impôts
allègements d'impôts sur le revenu
allègements d'impôts sur les sociétés
pour les petits d'entreprise prime pour
l'emploi qui est doublé parce que nous
pensions c'est comme ça qu'on va
relancer la consommation et faire
redémarrer l'activité donc le budget et
par erin pendant enfin laurent fabius
oui je vous en prie que les recettes
seront moins importantes que prévu parce
qu'ils ont il ya un risque de
ralentissement mais nous avons aussi
suite à bien sûr mais nous avons tenu
compte de cela l'hypothèse de croissance
que nous avons retenue et de deux et
demi pour cent avec un point bas à 2 25%
je prends un exemple parce que ça peut
paraître un peu théorique nous sommes
dit quelle va être la croissance des
états unis l'année prochaine nous avons
retenu une hypothèse de croissance de 2%
mon collègue américain vous le côtoyer
sans doute hier s'est exprimé et a dit
ce sera pas 2% de croissance aux états
unis ce soit 3,2 pour sortir qu'il est
plus optimiste que nous donc j'intègre
bien sûr les risques les possibilités
dans les prévisions si jamais il devait
y avoir une dégradation beaucoup plus
forte que celle qui est escompté à ce
moment là nous ferons nous ferons jouer
les stabilisateurs automatiques nous
ressent trion encore davantage sur
l'emploi et nous pensions que la banque
centrale baissera ce taux d'intérêt mais
ce que je veux dire c'est que au fond
nous sommes dans une situation d'une
situation il ya trois grands risques le
risque monétaire et financier nous avons
vu que jusqu'à présent il a été conjuré
le risque pétroliers et ça c'est
peut-être le risque économique le plus
important qui dépendra de la réaction
américaine et 2 qui sont les véritables
commanditaires de l'attentât parce que
dans le passé c'est la hausse des prix
du pétrole lorsqu'elle est intervenue
qui a amputé nos économies jusqu'à
présent et les marchés se tiennent bien
le pétrole augmente pas et puis il y a
le risque psychologique ce que les
ménages vont continuer à consommer et
donc le budget que nous présente au
stade budget réaliste qui tient compte
évidemment la situation mais c'est un
budget de volontaires parce que le point
que mesrine qu'on a dû tout à l'heure ne
comprennent peut-être pas ou qui ne
partagent pas c'est celui ci et ça c'est
pas de l'économie c'est je dirais d'une
certaine conception de l'humain les
terroristes ils ont tué des milliers
d'américains
mais il dépend de nous que les
terroristes soient rendus incapables
d'affaiblir notre économie et nous ce
que nous voulons pour la france et pour
l'europe en liaison avec les américains
et avec l'ensemble des pays du monde
sait que nous prenions les dispositions
pour empêcher ces terroristes a fait
bien notre économie et là dessus je
pense qu'il devrait y avoir plus d'union
entre les français
merci laurent fabius d'avoir été avec
nous on va rester à paris maintenant
avec vous antoine cormery pour le reste
de l'actualité en france et à l'étranger
aussi oui lionel jospin était
aujourd'hui sur le terrain le premier
ministre s'est rendu cet après midi à la
gare de lyon à paris pour se rendre
compte par lui même des mesures prises
dans le cadre de vigipirate desnel
jospin qui lors de ce déplacement
indiqué que si la france devait
s'engager comprenez dans une action
militaire bien le parlement seraient
consultés javits amer
cinq patrouilles en sous sol cinq
patrouilles en surface c'est le plan
vigipirate mis en place dans les gares
parisiennes et c'est l'information
presque le leitmotiv que lionel jospin
aura entendu répéter cet après-midi en
arpentant les couloirs du rer et les
escalators de la gare de lyon un peu à
la façon d'un général qui viendraient
voir si ses troupes assurent ou plutôt
dans la circonstance si elle rassure la
présence
oui tous ces choristes
ici depuis une semaine les interventions
policières sont souvent les mêmes ils
sont en crise
aujourd'hui lionel jospin voulait donc
apprécier les dispositifs de sécurité
mais pas seulement il a aussi évoqué la
réponse aux attentats et un éventuel
engagement français si
il était demandé d'une façon ou d'une
autre qui était posé la question d'un
engagement de la france
celui-ci à l'évidence ne pourrait pas
avoir lieu sans que le parlement est
était pleinement consulter dans la crise
née des attentats aux usa lionel j'ose
pas bien l'intention lui aussi de
montrer son implication à sa manière
celle des visites de terrain il y en
aura d'autres
changements d'affectation géographique
pour elisabeth guigou la ministre de
l'emploi et de la solidarité battu aux
dernières municipales à avignon par la
candidate rpr marie-josée rouag va se
présenter aux législatives l'an prochain
en seine saint denis elle postule au
siège occupé jusque là par la socialiste
véronique meyer qui a décidé de se
retirer
un revers pour l'elysée dans la sphère
des billets d'avion payés en liquide par
jacques chirac la commission pour la
transparence financière de la vie
politique estime que tous les éléments
du patrimoine d'un élu doivent être
déclarés il ya deux mois le palais
présidentiel avait estimé au contraire
que les indemnités personnel de jacques
chirac qui lui avait servi à payer des
voyages entre 92 et 95 étaient des
sommes qui par nature ne pouvait faire
l'objet d'aucune déclaration
cet avis de la commission avait été
demandé par les juges en charge de ce
dossier
lancement officiel de la concertation
publique sur les conditions de la
réouverture du tunnel du mont blanc le
préfet de rhône-alpes a présenté cet
après midi à lyon les éléments du
dossier aux responsables économiques
mais les associations de défense de
l'environnement ont boycotté la réunion
dans le
poursuivre pour une réouverture possible
à la mi-novembre
nouvelles perturbations sur le réseau
sncf après l'agression d'un contrôleur
le trafic des tgv entre paris et lille
sera très affecté deux mains par une
grève décidé après qu'un contrôleur et
été la cible de jeunes qui lui ont jeté
des cailloux en garde de croire delisle
trafic tgv perturbé mais aussi trafic
des trains express régionaux dans le
nord-pas-de-calais
football cet après midi au parc des
princes premier tour aller de la coupe
de l'uefa le psg et le rapid de bucarest
ont fait match nul 0 partout
si la rentrée littéraire a fait la part
belle aux romanciers les dramatiques
événements de la semaine dernière ont
conduit de nombreux lecteurs à
s'orienter vers des documents traitant
du terrorisme de l'intégrisme ou tout
simplement de l'islam pour tenter de
comprendre ainsi à la fnac étoiles à
paris les ventes de coran ont été
multipliées par quatre depuis mardi
enquête marie-jo jouant et frédéric de
large un éclairage une réponse un repère
voilà ce qu'il cherche depuis la semaine
dernière le public se jettent sur les
ouvrages qui pourrait avoir un rapport
plus ou moins directe avec la tragédie
du world trade center une des
conséquences inattendues le record de
vente du coran en rupture de stock dans
certaines librairies les gens ont besoin
de se retourner vers les textes
fondamentaux savoir un peu ce que l'on
dit aujourd'hui autour de l'islam est ce
que c'est vrai est ce que c'est aussi
dogmatique est ce que les slams le plus
souple donc avoir des repères ils
veulent à mon avis avoir un peu ce
qu'est le texte fondamental qu'est le
coran études et ses romans ce qui touche
à l'islam disparaît des rayonnages tous
essayent de comprendre les gens ont
éventuellement envie de savoir si
vraiment dans le coran il est dit que
foutu et toulouse j'ai entendu ce matin
à la radio que le coran permettait
toutes les excès
et qu'en particulier le khalife avait
tous les pouvoirs il était à la fois le
chef religieux mais le droit de guerre
etc alors j'essaie de me faire une idée
enquêtes sur le terrorisme ouvrages et
aux politiques suscitent également
l'intérêt très demandée avant même sa
sortie la biographie de bin laden
délaissée depuis son passage à l'an 2000
nostradamus est plus consulté que jamais
depuis les attentats les mesures de
sécurité ont été renforcées dans le
monde entier et certains marchands de
souvenirs en pâtissent c'est le cas de
ces vendeurs de couteau suisse à
l'aéroport de bâle comme mon père
sébastien leguay
400 objets confisqués aux voyageurs en
quatre jours et quel objet des season
manucure des limes à ongles et beaucoup
de couteau suisse pour la police de
l'aéroport le canif à croix blanche n'a
rien d'attendrissant derrière le
souvenir sympathique elle voit une arme
en puissance dans la boutique hors taxes
de peur que les voyageurs ne le glisse
dans leurs bagages à main il a été
carrément retirés des rayons aux grands
noms un tout petit remède préventif qui
mange pas de pain à la base ça peut
paraître bénin mais en fait
bon c'est de mettre les chances de notes
de l'autre côté pour éviter que certains
événements se reproduisent quoi
cependant le voyageur tenace saura très
vite qu'il est possible de se procurer
le fameux couteau quelque part dans
l'aéroport au kiosque à journaux ou la
vendeuse lui dictera sa consigne donnée
pas gage à main le couteau est interdite
par contre s'ils veulent ils peuvent le
mettre quand même dans leurs bagages
dans la soute heureusement la suisse
propose des spécialités moins ambiguë
pour les touristes qui tiennent à
réussir leur examen de passage au
détecteur de métaux
voilà pour l'actualité sur le vieux
continent on retourne à washington en
direct rejoindre david pujadas
oui antoine et je vous signale
d'ailleurs que les couteaux ont disparu
aussi à l'intérieur des avions c'est à
dire que les hommes d'affaires les plus
fortunés qui apprend que la classe
affaires doivent maintenant manger leur
foie gras avec des couteaux en plastique
voit la fin de cette édition donc de
washington dans un peu plus d'une heure
jacques chirac arrivera sur le sol
américain il sera reçu derrière nous ici
à la maison blanche par djordje bouche
avec qui il va dîner je vous rappelle
les deux principaux titres de
l'actualité de cette journée d'abord
l'annoncé faite par israël d'un retrait
de toutes les zone autonome
palestinienne et israël qui veut mettre
à l'épreuve les promesses de yasser
arafat d'un cessez le feu et puis la fin
de non-recevoir du régime des talibans à
l'ultimatum pakistanais nous ne
livrerons ben laden que s'il ya des
preuves formelles de son implication
dans les attentats dit-on à kaboul merci
de votre attention l'info prochain
rendez vous avec l'info sur france 2
minutes 40 le journal avec laurence
piquet de menthe et les matins à partir
de 6 heures 40 et edouard balladur sera
la lutte et de françoise laborde dans
les 4 vérités 13 heures daniel bilalian
à demain merci beaucoup de nous a lancé
tous
et
audi